[Music]
it's pretty
good that is pretty
good not the
best I got um I picked up two ciders on
my way home from the
weekend um and um this is not as good as
the other one I picked up the other one
was cider with Maple and vanilla that
one was this is honey crisp this is good
I ain't mad at it but I got two things
so you inevitably you're going to
compare them and one is the better
one um uh Pirates I saw that you you did
well on your nursing exam
congratulations on that and also saw the
earlier note about the uh the actor who
played the valard passing away and that
is that is a shame um he had a good run
though so but
still ah first time we managed to get to
a live stream well we're it's lovely to
have you
CCE yeah the the the maple vanilla was
oh that was Top Shelf this is
good not especially Miss Wicked Wolf no
not really um so for folks just joining
us um if you happen to be new here I
don't know I feel like we mostly have uh
just the regulars but just in case
um I will try and keep up with the chat
as best as I can there will be a period
in the Middle where I'm going to jump
over to the council of's disc and and
answer questions from there and um the
only way that I can guarantee that I
will see or respond to your comment or
question is to do it as a super chat
which will also get you a heart from me
I will try and keep up otherwise I just
don't make any promises otherwise that's
that's how that works do I like P
coladas and getting caught in the rain
they're okay if I'm going tropical I'd
rather go for a
daquiri hello from Scotland
ah there was part of me that was tempted
to go into what is probably not a very
good Scottish accent I showed restraint
because I've only just started but
welcome thank you very
much
ah the volume low are people uh people
hearing me all
right am I coming
through this is ground control to Major
t
I can't keep singing that because it's
copyrighted okay cool good to know when
did I first start wearing glasses I got
my first prescription glasses sophomore
year of high
school around the same time that I got
braces so that that that was that was a
lovely onew punch to happen back to
back
how do you prefer to listen to Big
finish Doctor Who MP3 downloads or CDs
well it's it's MP3 downloads by default
because I don't have a CD player in my
car
anymore um because it's it's difficult
for me to put something on CD like in
the house in a CD player and sit down
and listen to it the big Advantage for
audio for me is I can do something else
at the same time and so like uh CD is
great for the car but at this point I
don't have a CD player in my car most
cars most modern cars don't anymore
which is annoying um which the
equivalent would have been would have
been when I was younger complaining
about not having an eight trck player
I'm getting old um but yeah it's kind of
download by default
now don't worry about it I'm American
moved three years ago for school and I
can't do one well
I I'm sure you have a better grasp at
how at at the extent to which you can't
do it um because you have constant point
of reference me not so
much the main thing I'm missing right
now from not having a CD player in
my car anymore is my so I
have um the hisers GU to the G galxy
books on audio book but I have a very
specific one I have the version read by
Douglas Adams himself which I love and
is my favorite and is generally not the
version you can get when you buy digital
and I've only got those on CDs I've got
to rip those make those into
MP3s because I that used to be like if I
didn't have something else I need to
listen to that used to be Comfort
listening to me in the car and it hasn't
been
for 5 years now
now cocktail of choice depends on my
mood Paloma is kind of my go-to like a
default if I'm not in the mood for
anything
else um if I'm just like I'm not feeling
anything special today oh they have
Paloma I'll get a
Paloma I hate the frangi from Star
Trek
okay
oh enjoy doing doing that Blade Runner
question which is the better version of
v
bades i want more Lifeline uh the
original uh forgive me for swearing but
I I don't I do not think there is the
same power in the subdude I want more
life father as that moment when he goes
I want more life
[__] like we knew Roy
was
dangerous prior to that but something
about the way he hits that
word
oh it's it's it's the point at which you
realize
like the damage he's done up to now
wasn't just like he doesn't care about
the collateral damage he's actively
angry and it is so contained in the
delivery of that word I have a strong
preference on that it's my birthday
today turning 33 well happy birthday uh
Harriet having a nice dinner tonight but
the real party will be at galr 1 I will
be there so feel free to say
hi do I think Susan should come back in
the Sho gotua era at this point I think
it's a mistake to bring Susan back now
I'll put the usual caveat uh that I
usually put on these things which is
um maybe someone will come up with a
story that I that will actually be worth
it but honestly at this point so much
time has passed I I have a hard time
coming up with what you could do with
Susan that would be worth the waight and
wouldn't feel
gimmicky like at this point see th this
is this is why it's kind of an advantage
for me the fact that I don't do a lot of
speculation and I don't do a lot of
prediction and I don't do a lot of this
is what they should do I'm mostly just
here to see what actually happens but
but I do have it in my head that the way
to end Doctor Who like the show goes
away again like and you could revive it
again at a later date but like if you
wanted to put a button on it and be like
we're done for now what you do is you
have the doctor go back to
Susan and you know fulfill that promise
of one day I will come back I think
that's how you end Doctor
Who
and because I have that in my head I
have a hard time thinking of what else
to do with Susan that I would like as
much as that or I think would be as
impactful as
that I really want to get back to the
physical media I've already been
collecting vinyl
records uh as a friend friend has a
record player I want DVDs especially
since deloro endorsed them I'm real I'm
getting real mad at the number of things
that you cannot buy on physical media I
want a
physical copy of pona
so
bad and I can't it's not
available and uh last I checked only the
first three seasons of shiron and the
princesses of power is available in
physical media it's m
it is infuriating that these things
could be
gone aside Dungeons and Dragons what
ttrpgs do you play um regularly none
what have I played in the past I've
played gerps I've played um whatever's
the newer Star Trek system uh I've
played um Call of cthulu played a
Transformers system that was weird weird
um but yeah it's it's mostly been D and
D do I like the song Bad Day by Daniel
powder I did for a while I haven't felt
the desire to listen to it in a long
time not that I dislike it just like I
don't need that song right now do I
remember the first comic book you bought
slash
R morbius the living vampire issue three
because I I was so excited by Spider-Man
on the cover I didn't even bother to
double check that it wasn't really his
book that was how clumsily I started
getting into
Comics didn't the eighth doctor already
meet Susan again possibly I I like
there's a lot of big finish I haven't
listened to before but when it comes to
Canon I have said in the past and I
stand
by um everything in say big finish or
comic books or the novels is canon right
up until the point that the show uh
supersedes it which it is liable to do
at any moment do I like bork's music I
actually could not name you a single
bork
song like I've always been aware of her
more as a pop culture figure than as an
actual musical
artist I'm I'm not like I've probably
heard something from
her but
it's
possible that I haven't heard any I
certainly can't think of
any Council of Geeks has been more than
forever
Unfortunately they actually showed neona
in the theater here not long ago annoyed
that I missed it oh that sounds
nice it's Ken until it's not as a good
policy I mean I mean that's that is the
simplest way to say it
like
the big finish Audios in the books are
not aren't not canon they're generally
designed to fit in Canon but just
realize the show will never default to
them if the show wants to do something
that contradicts what the big finish or
what the novels have done the show will
just do
it Supreme Omega coming in with a first
Super Chat of the evening any nons
superhero comics and graphic novels you
like oh Fair few uh neona we'll shout
that out again um I really like
Snapdragon that was a really good
graphic novel uh the prince in the dress
maker that was a great graphic novel
um I'm trying to
think there were some that I liked that
I'm not going to name because I've got
too many issues with the creators at
this point there's a couple like that
unfortunately and I just I'm not in a
mood where I I feel like putting the
five million asterisks on recommending
it I just I just rather not
um I mean it's a web comic but sluggy
freelance we'll throw that out
there um I'm trying to think if there's
anything else that I want to name I mean
like I would argue that Sandman is not a
superhero comic even though it
technically takes place in the DC
Universe um so I'd throw that on the
pile
um what's oh crap I can't think of his
name all of a sudden hold
on
uh Richard
Mo um I don't think there's any issues
with
him um
but uh he
does um
let's let's go with he has a very cheeky
uh art style that I'm rather fond of
he's probably best known for Boneyard um
but I I do rather enjoy uh Far West
which was his and he's done he's done uh
he's done some friskier stuff than that
over the years I like I like his stuff a
fair bit and he he doesn't do
superheroes pretty sure he has it anyway
good grief if
any if any uh copyright holder of a
super hired Richard Moore to write them
I'd read it in a heartbeat and they'd
also deserve whatever they got it was
kind of like when Marvel hiled uh Milo
Manara to do that cover of Spiderwoman
and everybody freaked out and was like
oh my God she looks so sexualized how
did this happen you hired Milo Manara
that's how that happened what did you
think he was going to
do if you know the guy work they you
knew that was going to
happen did you know the compuer for the
Disney Channel theme passed away four
years ago oh I did not know
that my first was Spider-Man number 133
from 1974 was probably two years old and
got it in
ah solo solar eclipse is happening in
April
okay German Lefty Twitter's currently
coming up with new logos for various
subgroups of antifa logo for ADHD antifa
okay the fact that that's even a thing
that's adorable is a cute cartoon
squirrel in a
[Music]
hoodie we are here to fight Fascism and
oh
shiny girl genius yes thank you caroan
good PLL yes girl genius absolutely
deserves a a big shout out for non-s
superhero comic or graphic
novel The Squirrel being distracted by a
butterfly with a slogan distracted but
still showing up ADHD
antifa love it beautiful night of the
doctor kind of explicitly canonizes
Eight's big finish stories but the other
ones are firmly
non-binding yes and no Noah White
canonizes the companions not necessarily
the adventures
like so to put it in another way that
certainly that certainly would
indicate the audios are cannons or at
the very least eight audios are
Canon however if the show at some point
in the future wants to do something that
would flatly contradict something that
happened in that they're still G to do
it so to me all that truly canonizes is
that the doctor had those companions did
all the adventures happen and also
realize Canon is not a yes or no it's a
case by case like if something the show
does contradicts a big finish story that
doesn't invalidate all of big finish it
just means well that story is no longer
compatible you you need to divide it up
it's not uh All or
Nothing Tara staler thank you very much
for the Super Chat greatly appreciate
it uh hey Vera this is distressing me a
bit because I really enjoyed has been
hotel but someone on Facebook linked me
to a Google doc that documented accounts
of transm Miss Sandra behavior from its
creator um so I've
heard here's what I'm here's what I have
uh unfortunately learned I did not want
to learn any of this about hasbin hotel
it has a so far as I can tell very small
but very vocal and very dedicated
collection of
anti-fans who will claim often claim to
be fans of the show but who seem to go
all in on demonizing the the creators
some go after viip poop some go after
other members of the crew but there
seems to be a very uh aggressive anti
fandom for the creators of that show
does that mean that
the um accusations
are not uh valid or are untrue no not
necessarily but it's one of those things
because I yeah I've been sent links to
that stuff too um and while I'm not
going to say I don't think it's true I
am G to say I I am highly skeptical of
the motives of the people currently
spreading it it's one of those things
that like yes you have put stuff into a
Google
doc that I can't independently verify so
I don't think it's unreasonable to be on
the lookout a little bit but like the
thing to keep in mind is when stuff is
isolated to a Google doc if they're not
also sourcing directly to where it's
from and and it's still
up you don't know how they got what's in
there and you don't know what context
was stripped out of what they have in
there I'm always skeptical of anything
that lacks the ability for me to
personally verify and I say that while
also acknowledging that sometimes a
crappy person covering up their own
tracks makes it so I can't verify it
because if they delete the original
tweets or or Discord messages or
whatever then now is that me saying like
somebody just came with screenshots of a
conversation I will not believe that no
that's not what I'm saying
but
I'm given how highly motivated the anti
fandom of hasb been Hotel appears to be
and I mean they
are vicious this is actually something
in a roundabout way I might be
addressing at some point in the future
uh I don't want to talk too much about
that we'll see if it even happens but
just knowing the tone of the people who
are really pushing that idea of slamming
the original Creator and or members of
the
crew it makes me reluctant to uh or at
least skeptical to buy into that
narrative that is not me saying it's
definitely not true I'm not defending
bsy pop I'm saying uh I would like a
more reliable source to be uh saying
these things than the people who are
so there we
go is that a secret wrist cuff you're
sporting uh yes
Jen how nice of you to notice it is
indeed the secret wrist cuff which turns
into the spicy friendship
bracelet all right let's
see have I ever gotten mice in my house
you mean like as uh unwelcome guests
occasionally
is the doctor bisexual now arguably the
doctor's been bisexual the whole time
depending on how you want to Define
it uh it's been hinted
at
repeatedly um and I would say I mean
like short answer yeah like I did a
video years ago like is the doctor gay
now short answer yeah because the
doctor's own sense of gender is
fluctuating in flu ID so like when we
Define gay or bisexual straight As the
gender you are and and other genders
like if the doctor's gender is subject
to change which we now know for a fact
it is yeah the doctor if the doctor has
sexual interest at all they kind of have
to be bisexual or pansexual by
default just because even if like so say
for example if the doctors if all the
doctors love and
are of women or women presenting people
feminine
presenting okay so when the doctor is
male that makes him straight and when
the doctor is a woman that makes her gay
I would say that makes the character
looking at them collectively through all
generations bisexual or pansexual that's
another debate to be had Mouse is a
phenomenal non-s superhero historical
graphic novel prepis is also great
prepis I've read prepis is great the
movie adaptation is phenomenal
Mouse I'm slightly embarrassed to say I
have not read Mouse I know I should have
but it's one of those things like I
don't know if I have spoons for
something that heavy and every time I
think about it I'm
like like I've heard it's great I have
no doubt that it's great but I have not
read it am I any good at impressions are
there any particular are there any that
particularly impress others when you do
it I mean like I have a small handful of
ones nobody ever seemed to be really
impressed and they're all character
Impressions like they're not uh they're
not people Impressions like I could do
and like these are all related because
they're very similar voicewise I can do
Golem I can do Stitch I can do um oh
what was the other one I was thinking
jar jar Banks they all sound very
similar in terms of like the
vocalizations they're all very very
similar what's the difference between
anti- fandom and hate following I would
say that hate following are people who
just come in and are like this is crap
this is garbage and I think it's bad
anti fandom tends to have a very similar
level of fervor to actual fans like they
will get just as invested in a thing as
the fans do they will get just as
invested in learning about the creators
the behind the scenes all the people
involved but they do it in a way that
just spins into
vitriol so it's it's like the same level
of commitment as a dedicated fan but
it's done with anger so think hate
following Next Level I
guess can we stop harassing people who
worked on certain things for five
minutes oh that would be that would be
nice probably not but that would be
nice
um Jennifer
de deedo de
bened thank you for the Super
Chat I was laid off in November I was
just offer offered a job oh that's
wonderful uh happy I could keep my
patreon membership's up just super
chatting to celebrate oh thank you
Jennifer I appreciate that and congratul
ulations feels like I am a true fan
because I hate it more than anyone else
I think it I think maybe more accurate
is I'm a true fan because the problems I
have with it are the right problems I
hate it for the right
reasons
uh yeah it's it's it's weird out
there yeah
speaking of hasb been my biggest issue
with the season was its pacing it leads
me to question why Studios don't let
episodes of comedy series be longer than
25 minutes um when I eventually see the
last couple episodes I expect that to be
my primary criticism of the show overall
like just give just give it two or three
more minutes per episode honestly
because there have been more than a few
times where I felt like I turned over
two pages at
once what is the most overused Trope in
fictional
television
I mean the Romantic
subplot that that's
it uh perfect for daytime that's right
Jen perfect for daytime or
playtime Supreme Omega coming in again
do you view the 2008 recession and the
decline of Home Video Market as the
reasons why everything became so IP
driven in the 2010s to now in film um
um no I think it's just following the
money I mean if you're trying to nail
down why the money went in that
direction I think that there were a
handful of very successful well-known
IPS that made it clear that a
well-managed uh intellectual property
will make more money than almost
anything else and then everybody just
went that way because that's where the
money was how much the recession or uh
home video market decline factored into
that I don't know somebody could make
that argument somebody who's better at
research than I am could maybe make uh
or debunk that argument for me
corporations just go where they think
the money is and if somebody pulls way
ahead and is making more money than the
rest all the rest are going to go O How
how can we how can we approximate what
they're doing and when Marvel and you
know like Batman and stuff like that
blows up
into the the most successful biggest um
constantly cranking out highly
successful products kind of thing ever
yeah everybody moves that direction and
we tend to think of that in terms of
like well everyone tried to do an
interconnected universe and yes they did
but more fundamental than that milk your
existing
IP that's where the the bigger money is
do do I like avatar the Last air
bender I I keep I keep getting asked
this
intermittantly it's fine I saw it too
late I should have watched it when it
first came out I watched it or I watched
what I did watch of it significantly
later and as a result all the things
about it that are good and they are and
there's many of them and that at the
time we're groundbreaking in Western
anim
in terms of format and progress story
and serialized storytelling and the
character arts and how well it's
done it's not unique by the time I got
to it I've seen all the stuff that it
influenced some of which happens to be
more in my personal preference in terms
of the what the core material was so
I've I would I already knew that format
and how it inspired other things so I
know it's great and I know it's
important but it's like you know it's
it's it's going back to to a piece of
music that like inspired a musician that
you really love and you can hear the
bits that led to the thing that you love
but it's hard to appreciate that thing
that that came earlier if that wasn't
what you experienced first if any of
that makes sense I hope
so coyote aul I gotta hop over to the um
Discord in a minute I'm going to try and
catch up with the super chats first uh
with all this talk of hate them in
tonight's chat have you ever uh read
Evan dorkins the eling VIN the the
Eltingville Club should be Emanual on
don't do this if you're a fan of any
geek media I have never even heard of
that so uh
no as someone who hates Brian azarel is
Wonder Woman run as I do I'm curious
about your biggest issues with it if you
don't want to talk about it feel free to
say no short version Neco is uh
literally every single female character
in the three volumes that I read was
defined by a man from Diana to her
mother to I can't even remember her name
but the woman that Diana had to protect
every single woman of note in every
single page of those books was defined
and made important because of a man
either who she had sex with or who her
father was I.E who her mother had sex
with with so women in those in the
volumes that I read which I stopped
after three are defined solely and
entirely and
universally by the men that have somehow
sexually touched their lives either
directly or secondarily because it's who
their father is it is
so [__]
gross I'm sorry this is becoming a rant
I need to move off of it I'll just tell
you this NE the point the breaking point
was when uh Diana went down to Hades and
and like she's being groomed to marry
Hades and I I know Greek mythology I'm
already thinking Hades has a wife and
then we find out that the handmaiden
that's like prepping Diana is panie
hades's wife this doesn't matter this
has no impact on the plot but we had to
point out that the powerful woman who's
supposed to be here is a servant being
disregarded I
[__] Brian azarel's
writing I'm gonna be I'm GNA be that
level of
specific yeah I that I have no interest
in that man's writing ever was the worst
character on Family Guy
um I haven't watched Family Guy since it
started getting really
bad I don't
know I'm kind of done with all of them
at this
point Tommy mua not sure how to
pronounce it maybe that's correct thank
you for the Super Chat favorite color uh
forest green usually kind actually kind
of what I'm
wearing um Twi Lord my brain is looping
over a Sonic game reveal a one shot
often hated
19y old gone character who folks
including writer know I love is coming
back
huh
interesting Sometimes some stuff comes
back and it's like why is that a thing
but thoughts on Gravity Falls great show
awesome okay I gotta hop over the
Discord real quick I will be back um in
a couple of minutes let's see okay not
as many questions as I usually get on
there so hopefully this won't be too
long um and a reminder the Council of
Geeks Discord is a patreon exclusive
perk uh first up has the amazing
musician Reay R A ye hit your radar yet
she's a British singer songwriter I'm
currently obsessed want to share how
wonderful she is I have never heard of
her so nope not on my radar is there any
musician you're obsessed with I don't
think so I mean the closest I probably
came was Weird Al um but even than that
I'm not comfortable saying obsessed it's
just I think I bought more of his albums
than any other any other uh singer or
band that I've ever listened to but I
don't think I don't think any has ever
risen to the point of obsession with me
uh following your video about angel dust
and the representation of sex workers
okay here we
go uh have you seen the film personal
service or the TV show Secret Diary of
recall girl if so what do you think
about the representation in that no and
no I have heard of Secret Diary of a
call girl I haven't seen it I've not
heard of personal
service um you emphasized a number of
times in your video on has been hotels
handling of sex work that there were
things that you liked about the episode
what did you like um well first of all
to be clear if you put the focus on how
sexual assault and an abusive
relationship impacts a person it depicts
that very well so I don't even think
that's a flaw on the episode it just
bothered me that that was a story given
yet again to a sex worker
because of course they have to be
traumatized and abused and but like that
abuse and its depiction was done very
well the songs are great Poison's a
great song and loser baby is fantastic
um it like it's it's well as I said in
that video it does what it's doing very
well it's just what it is doing it's a
pattern that I really want to see
broken what do you think of the dynamic
between husk and Angel um I liked it I
like seeing I I I'm hoping that'll get
developed more in future I'm hoping it's
not going to be a case of like well we
saw them bonding this time and then we
can just assume they're besties like I'd
actually like to see that develop
further in some ways but I I like what
I've seen of
it uh do you have thoughts on how the
good place in hasb been Hotel each
handle similar concept I mean again as I
said in the video main difference is
tone like the core concept is very
similar but the tone of it is completely
different um in terms of
the mood intended to be evoked in the
audience because the good place while a
comedy is you know Broadcast Network
TV um you know that level of friendly
comedy and it's also fairly intellectual
and often
philosophical I would not call hasb been
Hotel philosophical uh in with any
particular depth so it's just coming at
the the similar core concept just a lot
more bluntly and um you know well while
saying [__] a
lot ah just re-watch your Strange New
World season 1 review so uh prompted by
your reaction to the fate of of one
character what is your biggest oh come
on reaction to the death of a
character
oh
oh see that's one of those things like
that's a really good
question that I am struggling to think
of another example off the top of my
head I know there's got to be more but
I
I I I wish I could Wrangle my brain well
enough to answer that because that's a
great question and I don't
know so I guess by default for right now
it's the character who I won't name in
season one of uh strange new worlds
because yeah that I was just really
starting I like I like that character to
begin with I was just really starting to
to Vibe with them and then they're gone
I'm like crying out loud is it time for
another run at the fin at the final
episode of the original de extra
run
no you'd have to pay
me do I get a third question after
asking that yes and that was it you said
in a recent video you still wear the cap
on occasion what situations inspire you
to put it on well the last time I put it
on was because I had just shoveled the
driveway my hair looked sweaty and gross
and I did not feel like going through
the rigma rooll of getting a taking a sh
and drying my hair and doing all this
just to sit down to talk about the
nonsense that was James Summerton
because that was the video um
just just uh mood it's rare that my mood
drifts in a way that I feel like putting
on the cap but in the case of that day
it's just like I don't want to deal with
my
hair uh what do you think the reason
behind the recent Surge and number of
people who were assigned female of birth
coming out as trans male see I'm not
going to have an opinion on that because
I want to see
reliable
information because I know that surge is
a popular narrative with people
who uh do not mean the trans Community
well that's not me saying that it isn't
happening but I am saying that the when
I so far when I have Tracked Down the
places that claim that I find a lot of
ugliness underpinning that claim um so
I'm I'm not going
to I'm not going to indulge the question
and it's not because of you asking but I
think that the framing that has drawn
that into the discourse and is making
that a question that people are asking
is largely being driven disingenuously
and so I am reluctant to engage with
that discourse at all at
present uh and the video about apology
you said that the best apologies have
the person explain what they're going to
do to change in the future how would you
approach explaining that you're going to
create a change of circumstances without
it sounding as though you're just trying
to justify the issue you've caused as
you being the victim of circumstance for
example I'm autistic and struggle a lot
with picking up social cues I end up
falling out with a friend because I
accused her boyfriend of not letting her
meet with friends when in reality she
was difficult to meet up with because
she had changed her mind about me meting
up with me and was hoping I'd get the
hint uh I wanted to send her an apology
ending with something along lines up I'm
going to work on my social skills so
that it won't happen again I ended up
not saying that because I thought it may
sound like I'm blaming my actions and my
lack of social skills and was refusing
to take responsibility i' see I don't
think personally that what you just
described is you not taking
responsibility the responsibility you're
taking is that your f failure to pick up
on social cues cause the problem and
you're owning up to that you're saying
I'm trying to fix that I don't think
that's trying to dodge responsibility
that's that is figuring out what the
problem is and trying to work on it so
it's it's OD to me that your original
question was framed as um how how would
you explain to you creating a change in
circumstance but like if the
circumstance is I am this way and I need
to work on that
that's taking responsibility and putting
out there how you intend to try and
adjust or at least account for how you
are so I don't think that's dodging
responsibility at all would it be
probably more helpful to have more
concrete things to offer than just I'm
going to work on getting better at this
yes what would those be in this specific
case I don't know I don't have an answer
to that but as a general rule the more
specific you can be in the the exact
things that you are going to do to get
better and the less it's just like this
is the problem and I'm going to work on
it like that's not nothing identifying
the problem is the start of making
anything better but I think the best
apologies not only identify
accurately the problem but set forth um
tangible things that uh you intend to do
in order to address
it okay that is it for for the Discord
so I am back in the
chat I'm really sorry if I add to your
stress by making you think of Brian
asell it's so like you need to
understand neku that um uh I I generally
have a rant in me just bubbling under
the surface at any time it doesn't take
much to launch me into rant mode and
sometimes like when I'm hanging hanging
out with people who just uh aren't up
for hearing me go off they have to be
like I like oh sorry right pull it
back because like I could just go off I
can it's a thing that can
happen H personal services based on the
autobiography of a famous ex worker and
Madam in the UK it's great film but it's
very transphobic SL indrop phobic scene
in it that is very cringe that is a
shame see Tiny Tunes Adventures or
Animaniacs
um
huh probably depends on the day you ask
me like I'll probably give a different
answer at different
times
favorite Cartoon Network shows Samurai
Jack season five didn't end well which
was
annoying have I seen either of the
reboots tiny tune Adventures or
Animaniacs nope oh did the Tiny Tunes
reboot actually happened I remember it
being
announced I did did that actually come
out I don't remember hearing a damn
thing about it actually coming out
Tiny Tunes looniversity oh I guess it
came out last
year
huh
okay that did that didn't make a splash
at all did
it h probably because like rebooting
that was the worst idea they could have
done to revive Tiny Tunes there is an
amazing beautiful concept for continuing
Tiny Tunes right in front of them and
they didn't they they didn't bother
doing it so uh allow allow me to to um
fan write for a hot minute don't reboot
Tiny Tunes
continue Tiny Tunes because you know how
old those characters were in the 90s
they're about my
age they're
Millennials they're Elder Millennials
they're in their late 30s early
40s and they went to Acme L University
on the Assumption and being taught by
the original Looney Tunes on the
assumption that they would become the
new stars that that would that was the
future that was promised
them and the original Looney
Tunes never went
away it is a
perfect
analog for the fact that older
Generations have refused to seed power
opportunity or wealth to Millennials or
gen Z for that matter like it's right
there it's right there there how do you
not just do
that
ah was right in front of them I missed
it by a
lot no let's just reboot it make them
kids again
why why so they so that you can update
the pop culture references who
cares a what a
waste
Twi
Lord ah let's see looks like we've got
some follow-ups here so the reason the
character is back so this is the Sonic
thing um is to frame another character's
life story mirroring Sonic's own time
travel story Sonic
has such complex
lore for a uh
anthropomorphized I'm G to say rodent I
know he's not a but I can never remember
what hedgehogs actually
are
so like his lore runs deep and it's way
more for me to ever keep up
with
uh and one more followup people are
reacting way more positively to him
because at this point he feels like a
correction to the franchise
overcorrecting for his game sometimes
bringing back a character who was
disliked previously is a chance to try
and fix what didn't work and and
actually you
know find or you know find a way to take
the original concept and give it another
shot I think that's one of the reasons
it's worth sometimes bringing back
forgotten
characters to be fair as cool as that
Tiny Tunes concept would be that's
giving way too much overall credit to
Looney Tunes uh so far subtext ah I
still say it's better than what they're
doing
uh do I know the lyrics of the an the
Animaniacs theme song yeah I won't be
singing them because I don't need to get
copyright
claimed I'm 100% trans myself
interesting John uh how do you figure
out the
percentages on that and what what is it
what does it mean to be 90% trans 60 35
like now now I'm really curious ious as
to how these percentages
translate favorite Nickelodeon show
o
h see the thing is I never really got
into Nick shows all that much like I
watched Nick aair bit because it just
had stuff that was targeted at my age
range and it was uh decent
background you know just something to
put on I don't I'm not sure there was
really much of anything on NE that I was
like o I want to be sure that I catch
this um at least not that I saw when I
was a kid and was relevant and it was
relevant to my
life yeah
I I'm not sure I have
one
act me lunity failed because they didn't
rehire the old voice actors well that
didn't help uh Jason th I wouldn't say
that's the reason it failed I would say
the reason it failed is they probably
didn't Market it worth a damn like like
I said I didn't even realize it had
happened I didn't watch the Animaniacs
reboots but I knew it happened so I
would say it's a failure of marketing
that probably didn't help because if you
aren't going to age them up or change
them in a significant way then yes fans
of the old show are going to notice
their favorite characters don't sound
like they used to so yeah if you're not
going to significantly change them then
yeah you should probably keep the
original voice actors if they're willing
to do
it I'm 20 20 20 20
20% trans him or both neither just me
I liked Ren and Stimpy just for how
Bonkers it was I never really clicked
with Ren and stimy even as a kid I
remember thinking like
this and like okay I know it's different
I know the the humor is different the
tone is
different
but it even at the time like a few years
later it would remind me of Beavis and
buad in that like yeah this is different
different but I'm not sure it's good and
like kids my age like thought that was
the that was the best stuff ever I was
like okay I youan like around the same
time freaking Adam Sandlers they're all
going to laugh at you album came out and
I had a bunch of friends who thought
that was the funniest thing on the
planet I'm
like
okay even young I was a comedy snob so
favorite Disney show H
gargoyles
yeah yeah I feel comfortable with that
coyote aul back
again just FYI the Eltingville Club is a
brutal darkart comedy comic about the
four worst stereotypes of fandom comic
sci-fi gaming and horror movies
oo
yeah Y no that definitely uh definitely
a lot to pull from I mean 0% trans
unfortunately there's nothing
unfortunate about that
Mars being trans or not being trans is
is not an
inherently good or bad thing it's just
being you so there's no need to put
unfortunately on
there do I prefer Doctor Who intros to
show the doctor's face or not
no with incredibly rare exceptions no
actually the only exception that uh the
the big exception that I'd make is got a
big asteris on it which is I like the
last set of credits they did for Pertwee
which is not just his face it's full
body and I thought that one worked I
actually like that one quite a bit but I
don't like the face it doesn't help that
most of the time the faces like the
still image just looks bad like oh some
of the ones that Tom Baker especially
like the like in his last seasons he was
like I don't know why they they use that
image oh it's not good it's not good so
yeah by and large I don't I don't like
the faces I'll tell you what
though Sylvester McCoy his face in
seventh doctor's intro is growing on me
although I suspect that is partially
because I am coming to deeply love the
seven doctor especially with Ace so like
I think I'm softening on the seventh
doctor's
intro largely because seeing it means o
I get to see the Seventh Doctor in Ace
so I don't know how much of it is me
warming to the thing itself or how much
of it is uh positive Feelings by
association but there is something about
his little his little wink especially
because like he's very clearly in
silverface paint
oh it's growing on me I still don't I
still don't like um that they picked
what I can't help but think of as the
heroic Bridge um from the Doctor Who
theme to make it as part of the opening
I I still I still think that's wrong
that's still that should not be there
that's for the
outro How the Grinch Stole Christmas or
Halloween is Grinch night well How the
Grinch Stole Christmas I mean Halloween
is Grinch night is underrated and
unfortunately far more forgotten than it
should be it's very good people should
find it people should watch it but it's
not
better sad fact the creative Ren and
Stimpy is very right ring rightwing
there's one season of adult Ren and
Stimpy that was cancelled by Spike TV
Spike TV thought it went too far yeah I
don't I don't want to talk about that
guy I'll tell you what it made it easier
to it makes it much easier for me to say
I never liked Ren STI and I never did
you know like it's I'm not trying to
claim I have predictive Powers but there
is something vindicating um
when creators whose work you never liked
kind of turn out to be terrible people
oh you know what I never thought renan
Stimpy was very good I never thought
Ricky jvas was funny so you know there's
something vindicating about that of
course then there's you know cases of
you know I did used to genuinely think
Dave Chappelle was funny and
was the first doctor actually sexist a
little a little
yeah I think it was overplayed in twice
upon a time but uh yeah a little bit
five minutes thank you caroan for that
heads
up Ace will always be famous wax doll
with a baseball bat like as well she
should be ace is like Ace is a great
companion but especially paired with
that doctor
like the thing is we and I include
myself in this because I've done
rankings of like the best companions
like we talk about the companions in a
vacuum but honestly the best it's about
the pairing it's about the dynamic it's
not just who the companion is it's about
the doctor that they're paired with
Seventh Doctor in Ace second doctor in
Jamie 10th doctor and
Donna these
are perfect Perfect
Pairings 12 doctor and Bill honorable
mention not quite as good as the other
three that I mentioned I don't think but
close like these characters in a vacuum
in another story paired with a different
doctor even would not work as well but
oh
just perfectly parir sixth doctor and
EVN SME so there's your big finish
recommendation six doctor and EVN SMI is
oh that was good because six
doctor
oh it really didn't help that during the
six doctors run on television the
writers really seemed like they hated
the companion it really felt like the
writers hated Perry and wanted her to
suffer and I don't know
why and it it is a major part of what
makes his TV era
bad have you decided what would be the
next Seventh Doctor serial you want to
see Paradise Towers might be a going to
go um before Mel appears in the 15th
doctor's era I have not um made a call
on that yet interesting recommendation
good rationale um I haven't made a call
on that because he's the the Seventh
Doctor is the one so I've seen all of
six doctor of the ones that I haven't
seen everything of Seventh Doctor is the
one I have the fewest left to see so I'm
kind of like sabering those as best I
can
ah Ryan Stimpy and be and buted were
unique because they were gross out shows
going mainstream popular okay I don't
like gross out humor
so there was there was a lot more
interesting animation going on at that
time or close to it even even from MTV
it I ah bugs me that be was and but head
was like the big breakout thing
when Aon flux and the Max and H the head
even were way more
interesting h
oh well rug Bratz is pretty good it's
it's it's all right um the good episodes
of Rugrats are very good but it's not a
show that I'm often just in the mood for
just like randomly if you know what I
mean uh we are I do have to wrap it up
soon Paradise Tower is on the short list
yes yes it is that is correct
Caroline never said it was a good thing
that's true coyote is you didn't say it
was a good thing but I mean it explain
explains why I didn't like
it um yeah and like e even be and but
head's own spin-off Dario was way
better just across the board and yes
correct goer the max was awesome
I
I will never stop loving the max the the
MTV series especially like the comic is
good I honestly think the show is better
and I understand the show doesn't do
that long a stretch of the comic I
honestly think the show is better I
think the concepts work better when you
hear the voices and when they're in
motion I love the Mac so
much oh so
good h
thoughts on pre-heart Nell doctors on at
this point what is there to have a
thought
on the fact that they exist don't like
it think it's a bad idea I like Joe
Martin I wish big Finnish would finally
release something with her I think they
announced it like two years ago that she
was gonna do stuff I don't think
anything's come out yet but like I want
to like her because she's great in the
part but you know
I don't think there's much to even have
an opinion on with pre hardal doctors
they're a thing
apparently
okay what's my favorite animated British
program I'm not sure I've seen very much
British
animation come to think of
it I don't Danger Mouse Maybe
I'm not sure battery running low okay
nek like I'm going to wrap up in uh just
a minute or two I just want to finish my
drink uh what if Joe Martin was the War
Doctor I don't I mean that would be that
would be very cool that moment would not
have landed part of the reason that
moment landed the way it did was because
it was John Hurt So I think the casting
was actually kind of vital for that
reveal did I ever watch Duck man a
little a little bit that was
that that show's not that show's not
smart that show's very
stupid I kind of got a soft spot for
that
one I haven't thought about that I
haven't thought about that show in ages
wow wson grommet or Shan the Sheep
um
I mood dependent I could go either way
actually one question then what do you
think the future of queer animated shows
will
be I don't know like I'm a bad person to
ask about the future of queer anything
because as a
consumer the fact that it's queer to me
should make a good thing great but it
won't make me interested in something
that I don't have a lot of interest in
otherwise like it it doesn't happen too
much anymore I remember super Ted as oh
crap oh super Ted oh I forgot about that
oh dang that's a memory
unlock [__] I forgot about
that oh anyways okay so um I I I I need
to answer the question and then I've got
a uh then I've got a Super Chat and I
need to finish this I need to call it a
night but
um so what was I oh uh yeah so the thing
is like for me the ideal kind of queer
show and it happens to be animated is
something
like she ran the princesses of power
like that show that
world those characters the action the
fantasy all of it is already good is
already something I'm interested in is
already something I want to see and then
it is queer on top of that similarly
honestly with something like pona while
I have said and I will continue to say
the queerness is completely baked in you
could not actually remove the queerness
from Neo Without completely changing it
from the ground up but even if you did
remove the queerness it would be nowhere
near as good it would be a shell of
itself but that's still an interesting
concept cep a someone who wants to be a
sidekick to a villain who seems to be
both more powerful and more bloodthirsty
than the villain they are a sidick too
in a techn fantasy setting like that's
already interesting and then you bake
the queerness in as much as neona did
ju like that to me is what I want to see
I want I want incredibly queer things
but I want the
pitch other than just the queerness to
be something I would already be going oh
that does sound interesting and a lot of
stuff that is like the front and the
front and um Center like queer
entertainment is like and look they're
gay together like okay yeah but what
else like I'm I'm gay on my own if I
want gay I can go out my front
door you know give me something more
than that of course I you know I say
that is a big lover of fantasy and
sci-fi so um it it's
it I want fantasy and sci-fi with
queerness in it I mean that's what I
personally want but that's just my taste
all right um last uh the Super Chat I
know words Sonic lore character is alien
warlord Satan
analog
okay sure why not made a deal with
eggman's Granddad created Shadow fans
were tired of disconnected stories I
guess that makes
sense that's a hell of a
sentence alien warlord Satan
analog wow
Sonic you do you
man all
right I am all
done money Mommy can we have have some
gay no honey we have gay at home I am
the gay you have at home all right I'm
calling a night thank you everybody for
joining me this has been fun I love
doing this thank you so much for being
here um take care of yourselves um be
well be safe be kind remember that you
are the council and I am just running
the meeting so until next time this
council is
adjourned
mavity